FRANK CHEN: So hi everyone.
I'm Frank.
And I work on the Google Brain
team working on TensorFlow.
And today for the first
part of this talk,
I'm going to talk to you about
accelerating machine learning
with Google Cloud TPUs.
So the motivation question
here is, why is Google
building accelerators?
I'm always hesitant
to predict this,
but if you look at the
data, this has been--
the end of Moore's
law has been going on
for the past 10 or 15 years,
where we don't really see
the 52% year-on-year growth
in single-threaded performance
that we saw from the late
1980s through the early 2000s
anymore, where now
single-threaded performance
for CPUs is really growing at
a rate of about maybe 3% or 5%
per year.
So what this means
is that I can't just
wait 18 months for my
machine learning models
to train twice as fast.
This doesn't work anymore.
At the same time,
organizations are
dealing with more
data than ever before.
You have people uploading
hundreds and hundreds
of hours of video every
minute to YouTube.
People are leaving
product reviews on Amazon.
People are using chat
systems, such as WhatsApp.
People are talking about
personal assistance
and so on and so forth.
So more data is generated
than ever before.
And organizations
are just not really
equipped to make sense of
them to use them properly.
And the third thread is
that at the same time,
we have this sort of
exponential increase
in the amount of compute needed
by these machine learning
models.
This is a very interesting
blog post by OpenAI.
In late 2012,
where we just had--
where deep learning was
first becoming useful.
We have like
AlexNet, and we have
Dropout, which used a fair
amount of computing power,
but not that much compared
to in late 2017 where
DeepMind published the
AlphaGo Zero and AlphaGo.
In the Alpha Zero paper, we
see in about six, seven years,
we see the compute demand
increase by 300,000 times.
So this puts a huge
strain on companies'
compute infrastructure.
So what does this all mean?
The end of Moore's law plus this
sort of exponential increase
in computer requirements means
that we need a new approach
for doing machine learning.
At the same time, of
course, everyone still
wants to do compute,
do machine learning,
training faster and cheaper.
So that's why Google is
building specialized hardware.
Now, the second question
you might be asking
is, what sort of accelerators
is Google building?
So from the title
of my talk, you
know that Google is building
a type of accelerator
that we call Tensor Processing
Units, which are really
specialized ASICs designed
for machine learning.
This is the first
generation of our TPUs
we introduced back
in 2015 at Google
I/O. The second
generation of TPUs
now called Cloud TPU
version 2 that we introduced
at Google I/O last year.
And then these Cloud
TPU version 2's
can be combined into pods
called Cloud TPU v2 Pods.
And of course, at
Google I/O this year,
we introduced the third
generation of cloud TPUs.
From air cooled.
Now it's liquid cooled.
And of course, you can
link a bunch of them
up into a pod
configuration as well.
So what are the differences
between these generations
of TPUs?
So the first version
of TPUs, it was really
designed for inference only.
So it did about 92
teraops of innate.
The second generation of
TPUs does both training
and inference.
It operates on
floating point numbers.
It does about 180 teraflops.
And it has about 64 gigs of HBM.
And the third
generation to TPUs,
it's a big leap in performance.
So now we are doing
420 teraflops.
And we doubled the
amount of memory.
So now it's 128 gigs of HBM.
And again, it does
training and inference.
And of course, we see
the same sort of progress
with Cloud TPU Pods as well.
Our 2017 pods did
about 11.5 petaflops.
That is 11,500
teraflops of compute
with 4 terabytes of HBM.
And our new generation of
pods does over 100 petaflops
with 32 terabytes of HBM.
And of course, the
new generation of pods
is also liquid cooled.
We have a new chip architecture.
So that's all well
and good, but really,
what we are looking for here
is not just peak performance,
but cost effective performance.
So take this very commonly
used image recognition model,
called ResNet 50.
If you train it on, again,
a very common dataset
called ImageNet, we
achieve about 4,100 images
per second on real data.
We also achieve that while
getting state of the art
final accuracy numbers.
So in this case, it's
93% top 5 accuracy
on the ImageNet dataset.
And we can train
this ResNet model
in about 7 hours and 47 minutes.
And this is actually
a huge improvement.
If you look at the original
paper by Kaiming He
and others where they introduce
the ResNet architecture,
they took weeks and weeks to
train one of these models.
And now with one
TPU, we can train it
in 7 hours and 47 minutes.
And of course, these things
are available on Google Cloud.
So the current training,
so it takes about--
if you pay for the resource
on demand, it's about $36.
And if you pay for it
using Google Cloud's
preemptible instances,
it is about $11.
So it's getting
pretty cheap to train.
And of course, we want to do
the cost effective performance
at scale.
So if you're trying the
same model, ResNet 50,
on a Cloud TPU
version 2 Pod, you
are getting something like
219,000 images per second
of training performance.
You get the same finer accuracy.
And training time goes
from about eight hours
to about eight minutes.
So again, that's a
huge improvement.
And this gets us into
the region of we can just
iterate on-- you can
just go train a model,
go get a cup of
coffee, come back,
and then you can
see the results.
So it gets into almost
interactive levels
of machine learning, of being
able to do machine learning
research and development.
So that's great.
Then the next question will be,
how do these accelerators work?
So today we are going to zoom
in on the second generation
of Cloud TPUs.
So again, this is
what it looks like.
This is one entire Cloud
TPU board that you see here.
And the first thing
that you want to know
is that Cloud TPUs are really
network-attached devices.
So if I want to use a Cloud TPU
on Google Cloud, what happens
is that I create it.
I go to the Google
Cloud Console,
and I create a Cloud TPU.
And then I create a
Google Compute Engine VM.
And then under VM, I just
have to install TensorFlow.
So literally, I have to
do PIP install TensorFlow.
And then I can
start writing code.
I don't have drivers to install.
You can use a
clean Ubuntu image.
You can use the machine
learning images that we provide.
So it's really very simple
to get started with.
So each TPU is connected
to a host server
with 32 lanes of PCI Express.
So each TPU-- so the
thing here to note
is that the TPU itself
is like an accelerator.
So you can think
of it like GPUs.
So it doesn't run.
You can't run Linux
on it by itself.
So it's connected
to the host server
by 32 lanes of PCI Express
to make sure that we
can transfer training data in.
We can get our results
back out quickly.
And of course, you can
see on this board clearly
there are four fairly
large heat sinks.
Underneath each heat
sink is a Cloud TPU chip.
So zooming in on
the chip, so here's
a very simplified diagram
of the chip layout.
So as you can see, each
chip has two cores.
It's connected to 16
gigabytes of HBM each.
And there are very
fast interconnects
that connect these chips
to other chips on the board
and across the entire pod.
So each chip does about-- each
core does about 22.5 teraflops.
And each core consists of a
scalar unit, a vector unit,
and a matrix unit.
And we are operating mostly on
full 32's with one exception.
So zooming on a
matrix unit, this
is where all the dense matrix
math and dense convolution
happens.
So the matrix unit is
implemented as a 128
by 128 systolic array that
does bfloat16 multiplies
and float32 accumulates.
So there are two terms here that
you might not be familiar with,
bloat16 and systolic arrays.
So I'm going to go through
each of these in turn.
So here's a brief guide
to floating point formats.
So if you are doing machine
learning training and inference
today, you're
probably using fp32,
or what's called
single-precision IEEE
floating point format.
So in this case, you
have one signed bit,
eight exponent bits, and
about 23 significant bits.
And that allows you to represent
a range of numbers from 10
to the negative 38 to
about 10 to the 38.
So it's a fairly wide range of
numbers that you can represent.
So in recent years,
people have been
trying to train neural
networks on fp16,
or what's half-precision
IEEE floating point format.
And people at TensorFlow
and across the industry
have been trying to make this
work well and seamlessly,
but the truth of
the matter is you
have to make some
modifications to many models
for it to train properly
if you're only using fp16,
mainly because of issues
like managing gradient,
or you have to do log
scaling, all sorts of things.
And the reason is
because the range
of representable
numbers for fp16
is much narrower than for fp32.
So the range here is just
from about 6 to the 6 times
10 to the negative
8 to about 65,000.
So that's a much narrower
range of numbers.
So what did the folks
at Google Brain do?
So what Google Brain
did is that we came up
with a floating point
format called bfloat16.
So what bfloat16 is,
it is like float32,
except we drop the last
16 bits of mantissa.
So this results in the same
bit, the same exponent bits,
but only 7 bits of mantissa
instead of 23 bits.
In this way we can represent
the same range of numbers, just
at a much lower position.
And it turns out that you don't
need all that much precision
for neural network training,
but you do actually
need all the range.
And then the second
term is systolic arrays.
So rather than
trying to describe
what a systolic array
is, I will just show you
a little animation I made up.
So in this case,
we are computing y
equals a very simple matrix
times vector computation.
So you're computing
y equals w times
x, where w is a
3-by-3 matrix and x
is a three-element vector.
And we are computing x
with a batch size of three.
So we have already
loaded all the weights
into the matrix unit.
And if we start the
first clock cycle,
you'll see that the first
element of the first vector
is loaded into the matrix unit.
And then we multiply
the position 1,
1 of w with the first
element of the first vector.
In the second clock
cycle, what happens
is that more weights are loaded.
So we are doing more
multiplications.
At the same time, we
are pushing the results
from the previous round of
multiplication [INAUDIBLE]..
So that in the case
of the yellow box
right there, we are not just
doing the multiplication.
We are also summing the result
of the multiplication that
happens within the box with
the result from the box
to the left of it.
And then this continues.
As you can see, you are
utilizing a lot more compute
now until you get
the outputs out.
So what this effectively is,
is a 2D field of compute.
So it allows us to put
a lot of compute units
within a very small
amount of chip area.
So if we optimize on the cost
of the chip, because the bigger
the chip, the bigger--
the higher the cost.
And with a chip architecture
that's also built
for pipelining-- that
is we can fill the--
so in this previous example, we
only had a batch size of three.
But if you have
bigger batch sizes,
if your chip architecture
is built for this,
you can just always
fill the matrix units.
And this means that we get very
high throughput for our matrix
multiplications, which is
really at the heart of a lot
of these deep learning models.
So OK, cool.
How do I use these accelerators?
So our recommendation is that
you start with our Cloud TPU
Reference Models.
These are high performance,
open source models.
They are licensed under, I
think, the Apache license.
They implement very common
and also cutting-edge
model architectures.
Internally, we test them for
performance and accuracy.
And you can use these and get
up and running really quickly.
And you can modify
them as needed.
So you can train and run, of
course, on assembled data,
on your own data, and
so on and so forth.
And we have a lot
of reference models.
So I gave you examples of ResNet
50 and other image recognition
networks, but you
can also do things
like machine translation,
language modeling, speech
recognition, image generation.
We have all these models just
as sample models for cloud
TPUs if you want to
get started with them.
Great.
So remember these?
Remember those pods?
It turns out for a
lot of our models,
we have not only optimized
them for single TPUs,
we've also optimized
for TPU pods.
For instance, take
the ResNet 50 example
that I quoted performance
figures for earlier.
In this case, you've got
training on a single Cloud TPU.
This is really
literally all you do.
You download the--
you start a TPU.
You download TensorFlow.
You clone the Git repository.
And then you just basically
call Python, and just
say, point it to the TPU.
Point it where our data is.
Tell me what the batch size is.
Tell me how many steps
you want to train for.
And then bam.
Off you go.
It turns out that training
on the Cloud TPU Pod
is not that different.
Instead of starting a Cloud
TPU, you start a Cloud TPU pod.
And really, the only
things you have to modify
is the name of the
TPU, the training batch
size, and the number
of training steps.
So the reference model-- so in
this case, the reference model
for ResNet 50 uses like
fairly recent techniques,
such as the LARS optimizer
and label smoothing
to achieve the
target accuracy so
that you don't have to
re-implement all these changes.
We have already done it for you.
So a lot of our reference
models scale up from one
TPU all the way to a pod.
So of course, you aren't
limited to reference models.
So when you build your
own models, of course,
you build them with TensorFlow.
And when you build
models with TensorFlow,
there are really two things
that you have to think about.
There is the thing that most
people focus their energy on,
which is the network
architecture itself, which
is running on the accelerator.
But a lot of what people
neglect is the input pipeline.
So basically, moving
our training data,
reading them, decompressing
them, parsing them,
performing data augmentation,
and patching them,
and then sending it
into the accelerators.
A lot of people don't think
about this as a problem,
but really, for these sort of
high performance accelerators,
this sort of limits performance,
because if your training
pipelines slow, then accelerator
is just idle half the time.
So phase one, build
an input pipeline.
So this is a very simple
input pipeline for ResNet 50.
So you have an input function.
You list a bunch of files.
You shuffle them.
You repeat them.
And then you send it out.
So this is great.
Guess what the
performance of this.
This is 150 images per second.
So even if you run
this on the Cloud TPU,
you're getting 150 images per
second for training, which
is not great, because Cloud TPUs
can do 4,000 images per second.
So what you do?
You have a bottleneck.
So how do you
improve performance?
You find the bottleneck.
You optimize the bottleneck.
And of course, you
repeat until you
get the desired performance.
And Cloud TPUs actually provide
a fairly comprehensive set
of profiling tools.
So in this case,
you can see what's--
in this case, this
is TensorBoard.
So you can bring up a profile
of what's happening on your TPU,
on the host, and
so on and so forth.
And then you can see that,
oh, there are large gaps.
So this means that the CPU
is idle waiting for data.
And this is not great.
So a simplified
like representation
of what's happening on
TensorBoard right now
is something like this.
So in this case,
we have an extract.
We have a transformer
with a load.
And then we have the
training on the accelerator.
And they are all
happening sequentially.
And this is not great, right?
Because what is
really happening here
is that you're
leaving the CPU idle.
And you're leaving
the accelerator idle.
And these two things are
the biggest cost factors
in your training pipeline.
So what you really want to do
is to do something like this.
You're overlapping
every single step.
And you are utilizing all of the
expensive bits in your computer
to the fullest extent.
So the accelerator
is 100% utilized.
The CPU is only idle slightly.
And the disk is idle,
but that's fine.
And to do pipelining
is really easy.
So you just have to
really modify one thing.
So you see the
second to last line.
Instead of doing-- just
do dataset.prefetch.
And this just ensures
that everything above
is pipeline with
accelerator training.
And of course, you also
want to do parallel reads,
because reading from
many files is faster than
reading from one.
And there are many
other techniques
that I won't go into today,
because I don't have time.
So you can use sloppy
interleave, fused dataset
operators.
We have a good performance
guide on the TensorFlow website
that tells you how you can
optimize your input pipelines.
I encourage you to take a look.
But this is sort of a partially
optimized input pipeline.
It's slightly longer
than our simple one,
but this does over
2,000 images per second.
And if you want the fully
optimized image pipeline,
please take a look at
our TPU sample code.
OK.
Cool.
Now comes the fun part,
building your model.
So the first way you
can build your model
is actually with Keras.
So we have experimental
Keras integration available
starting with TensorFlow
1.11, which will be coming out
in about two to three weeks.
So you can build--
so you can write your models
in Keras as per normal.
And the only real thing
that you have to modify
is basically create what's
called a cluster resolver,
give it a name, create
a distribution strategy,
and call the
keras_to_tpu_model function.
And this will
transform your model
to something that's
compatible for the TPU.
And then after
that, you can just
do the simple sort of
model.compile, model.fit,
and all the Keras goodness
that you know and love.
And in TensorFlow 1.12, which
is the release after this,
we are going to
make it even easier.
So you don't even have to call
keras_to_tpu_model anymore.
You can just call
model.compile directly.
And then this will work.
Great.
You don't want to use Keras.
You want to use
something lower level.
So we also have a
solution for that.
You can use something called
TensorFlow Distribution
Strategy.
I think there was a talk
about Distribution Strategy
yesterday.
So if you missed that, I think
the video will be online soon.
So you should take
a look at that.
So in this case, this
is using the estimator
of Distribution Strategy.
So you can write
your model function
like you see on the left.
You can write your
input function
like you see on the top right.
And again, the only thing
you really have to modify
is a couple lines.
Again, create a cluster resolve,
or create a TPU strategy.
And then you can just pass it in
through the estimator function,
train.distribute.
So this will let
it work on TPUs.
So that's all great.
And so are people
using these TPUs?
People are, in fact.
So here's a case study of an
architecture search project
that's done by a group
from Stanford and MIT.
So they did parallel runs
using hundreds and hundreds
of cloud TPUs from the
TensorFlow Research Cloud
Program, which is where we
are providing 1,000 free TPUs
to academic researchers.
So if you're
academic researchers,
I encourage you to
look into this program.
So each blue dot in this image
is a run on a TPU training
an ImageNet scale,
a convolution RNN.
So each run used to
take hours and hours
to train on other
hardware, but on TPUs,
because they have
access to so many TPUs,
they can do hundreds and
hundreds of these runs.
So what they were
trying to do was
that they were trying to search
for a model that was a better
fit for the data
that you record, say,
if you put electrodes
in my brain
and look at what my
visual cortex is trying
to do when I look at things.
So they are trying
to find analogs,
trying to find a
neural network that
was a closer analog to
the primate visual cortex.
So it turns out that-- so
here's a diagram of the space
that they were searching.
And it turns out that
across a population
of many different
models, they found
that the red connections
were sort of selected
for the search
versus the others.
And what happens is
that they went back
and compared the models
to some of the signals
that were recording, that the
biologists were recording,
and they found that the
convolution RNNs were
a much better fit
for neural signals,
for instance, in v4,
in IT, than in other
[INAUDIBLE],, like convolution,
or feet forward models
that you see in the
literature today.
So this is a really new
and exciting direction
that a research group was able
to do from scratch with access
to lots of compute.
So you can not just
train models on TPUs,
you can search for them
basically automatically, too.
And so, finally, of
course, Cloud TPUs today,
Cloud TPU version 2
today is available,
is generally available
on Google Cloud.
If you want to learn
more about them,
go to cloud.google.com/tpu
to get started.
All right.
So now Alex will present
some new functionality
that lets you write the
accelerator code more easily.
Alex.